[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DODD THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
[inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT
OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE GALLERY PLEASE RICE.
WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
SISTER LIBBY FERNANDES FOUNDER
THE MERCY PALLARS AFTER WHICH
WILL REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
BY DOCTOR PAN. FOR THE EXPANDING
GRAND TOUR OF CREATION WE GIVE
THANKS THIS DAY. FOR THIS
FRAGILE PLANET.
WE GIVE THANKS THIS DAY. FOR THE
JOY OF HUMAN LIFE.
ITS WONDERS AND SURPRISES WE
GIVE THANKS.
WE PRAY FOR FAITH WITHOUT
BANDAGES AND FOR UNDERSTANDING
OF VIEWS NOT SHARED.
WE PRAY FOR ALL WHO LABOR AND
SUFFER FOR A FAIRER WORLD.
WE PRAY THAT WE MAY LIVE NOT
FIRE FEARS BUT BUYER HOLDS.
NOT BY OUR WORDS BUT BY OUR
DEEDS A MAN.
AND THANK YOU US AS WE CELEBRATE
THE INDEPENDENCE DAY FOR OUR
GREAT NATION LESS SALUTE OUR
FLAG TODAY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE IN.
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH ONE IS
[inaudible]
REVIEW
ART MEMBERS WERE MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
DOCTOR PAN ARE YOU READY FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTION OF GUEST.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
JUST WANTED TO I HAD SOME
RELATIVES COME VISIT I JUST WANT
INTRODUCED THEM ON THE FLOOR SO
I SO PLEASE -- WELCOME MY
BROTHER IN LAW.
WHEN J. WEIGHING HIS WIFE --
CHOICE LEND MY NEPHEW -- WARREN
AND MY SON'S CAR COMPANY AND
ALEXANDRE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME.
TO TO A WARM CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WELCOME TO THE FAMILY
.
OUR MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS A WROTE RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNAL FOR JULY FIRST THROUGH
JUNE JULY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE COLOR.
LEARNING CENTER MORE OCT FOR
WHAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU IS PRESIDENT I'D LIKE
TO PULL AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
BILLION ON IT.
SENATOR HILL FOR PURPOSES THANK
YOU MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
QUIRK FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
CLERK WILL KNOW.
FILE ITEM [inaudible] EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN THANK YOU.
OUR CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE.
SENATE CIRCLE READING.
ITEMS.
ONE TO THIRTY FOUR THE SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY SEVEN AT THE
MOMENT ONE THIRTY NINE WITH THE
MOMENT NINE NINETY ONE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN SOME ABOUT
TWELVE ANYONE WITH THE MOMENT
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WITH AMOUNTS TO
OVER TO WITH THE MOMENT.
624-130-3690 SEVEN WITH MEMBERS
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE WITH A
MOMENT'S EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN WITH
WOMEN SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE FIVE
TWENTY THREE WITH A MOMENT'S.
FORTY NINE WITH MEMBERS EIGHT OH
THREE WITH A NUMBER SEVEN A
SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT SIXTEEN OF
SEVEN WITH A MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ [inaudible]
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
NO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
SENATE THIRD READING.
WE HAVE ITEM.
FIFTY ONE CENTER Y. KASKI ARE
YOU READY FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
YES I AM MISTER PRESIDENT
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE THE RELATIVE
TO THE BASE OF CONVENTION.
SOONER ACOSTA MEMBERS MISTER
PRESIDENT THE GLOBAL TRANS
BOUNDARY WAY STREET IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY IT
INCLUDES TOXIC WASTE
MANUFACTURING WASTE.
ELECTRONIC WASTE AND PESTICIDES
AS WELL AS RECOVERABLE MATERIALS
FOR FINAL DISPOSAL AND RECYCLING.
BESSIE INDUSTRY GREW IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
THERE WERE SEVERAL HIGH PROFILE
INCIDENTS OF WASTE DUMPING AND
ACCIDENTS AT SEA AS WELL AS
STORIES OF WEALTHY NATIONS
DUMPING THEIR WAY SOME POORER
NATIONS. FOR THE BASEL
CONVENTION CONVENE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE PLACE PROTOCOLS
ON INTERNATIONAL WAY STRAIGHT
REQUIRING PRIOR CONSENT.
FROM THE RECEIVING COMPANY TO
ACCEPT WASTE THEM RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS AND WHILE THE UNITED
STATES SIGNED THE CONVENTION AND
THE SENATE GAVE APPROVAL IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO CONGRESS TO
THIS DAY MISTER PRESIDENT HAS
FAILED TO AMEND THE FEDERAL LAW
TO CONFORM TO THE CONVENTION.
AND BY FAILING TO MEN THE
FEDERAL LAW IT PREVENTS
RATIFICATION AND PARTICIPATION
IN THE CONFERENCE OF THE PARTIES.
THAT HAS EXPANDED THE
CONVENTIONS PROTOCOLS BECAUSE WE
HAVE FAILED MISTER PRESIDENT TO
RATIFY THE CONVENTION.
THE UNITED STATES HAS HAD TO
NEGOTIATE COSTLY AGREEMENTS WITH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES TO SEND THE
RECEIVE WICKS.
THE MOST RECENT CONFERENCE OF
THE PARTIES ARE WE CALLED THE
COP HELD IN MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
ADDED CONTAMINATED THE MIX
PLASTIC WAYS TO THE CONVENTIONS
PROTOCOLS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MEMBERS OF
THIS FLOOR ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
S. R. FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
BEFORE US STATES THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS THE BASEL CONVENTION
AND CALLS ON CONGRESS TO AMEND
THE FEDERAL LAW TO ALLOW THE
UNITED STATES. TO FULLY RATIFIED
THE CONVENTION AND TAKE PART IN
THE COP
S. R. FORTY SEVEN POINTS OUT
THAT THE FAILURE TO RATIFY THE
BASEL AFFECTS MANY CALIFORNIANS
BUSINESSES AS WELL.
AS THEY OFTEN DO BUSINESS WITH
COUNTRIES ND ARE BOUND BY THE
CONVENTION WASTE PROTOCOLS.
MANY CALIFORNIANS CANNOT RE
IMPORT PRECIOUS METALS AND
MATERIALS FOR RECYCLING INTO NEW
PRODUCTS.
THE CALIFORNIA VOICE GOES ON
HEARD IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS
WITHOUT THE UNITED STATES AT THE
TABLE MISTER PRESIDENT.
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRESS IN WASTE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING HAS BEEN HINDERED BY
CHINA'S TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BAD ON SOME OF THE PLASTICS THAT
THE RECYCLABLES AND OUR PROGRESS
THE PROGRESS THE CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO HIT BARRIERS.
IS LONG AS UNITED STATES STAYS
OUT OF THE ENVIRONMENT TREATING
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE ONS. R.
FORTY SEVEN AND ADDS
CALIFORNIA'S VOICE THIS
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL TREATY.
THANK YOU IS FROM CENTER MORE
COSTLY SENATOR BORDERS.
THEY GIVE IS PRESENT AS ONE TO
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
FREMONT I THINK -- THIS IS A
SMART MOVE MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WHEN WE HAVE BUSINESSES THAT
RELY NOT ONLY ON THE EXPORTING
OF THOSE MATERIALS BUT THE
IMPORTING OF THEM BEING A PART
OF THE REGULATION THE PROTOCOLS
GIVES IS THE THE TABLE?
AND KEEPS US ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS SO I COMMENDED THEY'LL
BE SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING TING UNSER ACOSTA WHICH
LIKE CLOSE HIGHER TONIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL.
HILL.
HI WITH SOME [inaudible] FOR
TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
BY COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI
BECAUSE HE MOVES CALL.
MOVING ON DOWN TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING [inaudible]
SECRETARY.
THERE WE HAVE IT THE REST
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY SIX SENATOR
RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED
[inaudible]
NO SHE ABOUT SOME FILE.
FILE ITEM FILE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE SENATOR HILL ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS I DON'T.
BASS ON FILE.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE BY SEN ASSEMBLYMAN
GARCIA MISS SENATOR ALLEN ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THE SIDE.
MISS SECTOR PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINETY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACT REALLY TO GREENHOUSE
GASES.
SENATOR ALLEN WELL GOOD MORNING
SENATORS I WANT TO PRESENT AB
TWO NINETY THREE ON BEHALF OF A
SOME MEMBER -- AND WHERE GARCIA.
THIS BILL PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
DIRECTION TO THE COMPLAINTS
OFFSET PROTOCOL TASK FORCE WHICH
IS.
SAID TO BE CONVENED BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD LATER THIS YEAR
TO LOOK AT OFFSET OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR ENHANCE MANAGEMENT OF
CONSERVATION OR CONSERVATION OF
AGRICULTURAL OR NATURAL LANCE.
SO AB THREE NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
RECALL I WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN REQUIRED A
CRITTER REQUIREMENT.
THAT AT LEAST HALF OF THE ASA
CREDITS USE FOR COMPLIANCE IN
OUR CAP AND TRADE.
AFTER -- TWENTY TWENTY MUST
PROVIDE A DIRECT BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER WE'VE HEARD
CONCERN THAT THERE SIMPLY AREN'T
ENOUGH OFFSET CREDIT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL ENABLE
COMPLIANCE.
WITH THIS NEW REQUIREMENT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO POINT THE
AIRPORT IN THE DIRECTION SOME
IMMEDIATE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT WE STAY ON TRACK.
WITH THIS IMPORTANT VISION THE
LAW AND I RESPECT RESTAURANT
ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
IN.
NINETEEN NINE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD.
I COVER YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
BY DAILY.
BY DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROSS BY.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I AMBER.
WHAT COUNTY?
HI WINNER.
BY WILK HI -- ALAMOS A CALL.
NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY BY SIMPLY ONE GARCIA A
SINNER ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM.
YES THE SECTOR PLEASE ROUTE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY DRINKING WATER
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALAN.
I THANK YOU I'VE MISSED
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THAT AB
SEVEN FIFTY SIX WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO ISSUE ONE NOTICE.
INSTEAD OF HUNDREDS.
AS THE MOVE INTO PHASE TWO OF
INVESTIGATIVE TESTING
[inaudible] FOR PER FLORA COAL
SUBSTANCES COMMONLY KNOWN AS P..
FIVE THE P. FIVE'S REFERS TO A
CLASS OF CHEMICALS THAT ARE
RESISTANT TO WATER OIL AND HEAT.
BUT WHICH HAVE ALSO BEEN LINKED
TO CANCER AND BIRTH DEFECTS
THESE CHEMICALS ARE ALSO
PERSISTENT IN THE HUMAN BODY IN
THE ENVIRONMENT.
MEANING THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN
THE CAN ACCUMULATE OVER TIME.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR USE IN
PROCESSING IN MANUFACTURING AND
AS AN ADDITIVE IN FIREFIGHTING
PHONE THESE CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN
FOUND IN WATER ACROSS THE NATION.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S MORE
CONTAMINATION DEFECTS DETECTIONS
OF THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
CHEMICALS THAN ANY OTHER STATE
THE WATER BOARD.
IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON A PHASED
INVESTIGATIVE TESTING OF WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE SUSPECTED TO
HAVE DEFIES COMMON CONTAMINATION.
THESE AREAS INCLUDE WATER
SYSTEMS NEAR AIRPORTS AND
MILITARY BASES WERE LARGE STORES
OF FUEL ARE HAVE BEEN STORED IN
FIREFIGHTING PHONE MAY HAVE BEEN
USED.
NEW MANUFACTURING SITE.
THEY USE THE SB FIVE CHEMICALS
IN THOSE SURROUNDING.
PREVIOUS P. FIVE DETECTION.
NOW THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE WATER BOARD'S
CURRENT EFFORTS IN LET CONSUMERS
KNOW WHAT'S IN THEIR WATER BY
REQUIRING NOTIFICATION SIMILAR
TO THOSE.
RECOMMENDED BY THE WATER BOARD.
NOW RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU RICH PRESIDENTE -- THE
CONCERN I HAVE WITH THIS BILL.
IS THAT THE WATER BOARD IS
ALREADY SARTING.
TO TELL WATER DISTRICTS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO NOTIFY.
THEIR CUSTOMERS WITHIN A REASON
SHORT PRETTY TIME.
THAT THIS MAY BE APPLICABLE EVEN
THOUGH THE AMOUNT IS SO.
NEGLIGIBLE I'M JUST A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT WERE.
UP PUSHING OUR WATER DISTRICTS A
LITTLE TOO HARD TOO FAST WHEN
THE WORKING.
DILIGENTLY ON THIS MATTER SO I I
WILL BE OPPOSED -- TO A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION IS
CHRISTIAN OF EIGHT ON THIS ITEM.
THE NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR WHICH
ARE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I MEAN I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS I I
WILL JUST KIND OF EMPHASIZE THAT
ALL THIS DOES IS AUTHORIZED --
THE BOARD -- TO IT TO HAVE WATER
SYSTEMS MONITOR FOR THE
SUBSTANCES AND AND AND THEN THE
ADULTS ONLY DO SO IF THEY FIND
IT NECESSARY SO -- WITHOUT
RESPECT FASHIONABLE THANK YOU.
MISTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
INSIDE.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DOT.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO -- TADO
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BY CASKEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
ALLEN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA RETURN TRUE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS AND WERE
TAKING UP.
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN CENTER
WIENER ARE YOU PREPARED.
WITH THIS ITEM.
THE SECTOR PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL THIRTY BY SENATOR
WINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP SOONER
WINNER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES US SENATE
BILL THIRTY IS -- BACK ON
CONCURRENCE -- IN THIS BILL WILL
AND DISCRIMINATION ON THE
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP REGISTRY
AGAINST OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS.
ALL SAME SEX COUPLES TO ENTER
INTO DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS --
BUT FOR OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES ONE
OF THOSE PARTNERS MUST BE AGE
SIXTY TWO OR OLDER -- SB THIRTY
WILL AND THAT DISCRIMINATION AND
ALLOW ANY COUPLE SAME SEX OR
OPPOSITE SEX TO ENTER INTO A
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP -- WHEN
THIS BILL WAS IN THE SENATE --
EARLIER THIS YEAR IT WAS KEYED A
TAX AND ARE SUBJECT TO A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IN THE ASSEMBLY WE
WORKED OUT AMENDMENTS -- THAT
REMOVED THE TAXI AND IS NOW A
MAJORITY VOTE.
WE ALSO ACCEPT THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS -- TO MAKE CLEAR TO
PEOPLE SEEKING A DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP THAT UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW THEY'RE SUBJECT
TO ALL THE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
OF SPOUSES ARE COLLEAGUES ALL
RELATIONSHIPS ARE DIFFERENT AND
PEOPLE HAVE REASONS FOR MAKING
DIFFERENT CHOICES ABOUT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP.
SB -- THIRTY WILL HELP ALLOW
PEOPLE TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES FOR
THEMSELVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THIS I
DON'T.
HEARING SHE NINE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS.
I BRADFORD ART I CARRY IT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DOT.
ARE THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO -- TADO
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
BY A BURKE.
WHY COUNTY?
I WINNER.
HI WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES [inaudible]
HI.
GROVE HUESO JACKSON JONES.
MITCHELL MONNING MORLOCK
[inaudible]
I MORRELL NIELSEN [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ICE TWENTY NINE OH ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MINUTES ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE ABOUT TO LIFT THE
CALLS.
OUR FIRST ITEM WE'RE LOOKING
CALL ON IS ITEM.
FIFTY ONE THE SECRETARY WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THIS IS DOCTOR CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
WITH SO.
JACKSON JONES MITCHELL MONNING.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL NIELSEN [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
OURS TWENTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NEXT UP IS ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY.
GROVE.
HUESO JACKSON JONES MITCHELL
MONNING MERRELL.
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
EXCEPT MEMBERS IS ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE FORTY THE SECRETARY.
I'M SORRY SENATOR BATES WHAT
PURPOSE.
MR PRESIDENTE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
IN THE **** LOUNGE PLEASE.
WHAT DO WOMEN AT TO LOOK THE
CALL?
OKAY.
WE'RE LOOKING TO CALL ON A ON A
WALL AND ONE FORTY RESEARCHER
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES -- OFF FOR JUST
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN NO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
SENATOR ALLEN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO GO.
FOR BRIEF CAUCUS RICARDO THANK
YOU WERE.
CENTER HERTZBERG WROTE PURPOSE.
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THE MADDING
LOUNGE.
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN MANY LAUNCH
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE [inaudible]
LUCIEN SIR.
MISTER PRESIDENT SO I MOVE TO
SUSPEND SENATE RULE TWENTY ONE
POINT [inaudible]
TWO THANK YOU.
MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
HI ARCHER I DEMOCRATS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES.
NO BELL.
I PORCHES.
BRADFORD ART I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
NO GALLEY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH WHEN TWO
PEOPLE HERTZBERG HI AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BY COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
NO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NO.
GROVE WITH SO.
JACKSON JONES MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL MONNING MORALE
SKINNER STERN.
NUMBER. TWENTY TWO A DAYS NO.
TWENTY TWO EYES NOSE EIGHT THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MR MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
ALSO MOVED TO WAIVE JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO A FOR THE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE TO MEET AND HEAR A
BEAT TEN FIFTY FOUR ON MONDAY
JULY EIGHTH.
BUT IN JULY.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE THE
DAY THANK YOU SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
NO OUT THERE BUT FOR WHAT
PURPOSE.
I WISH TO OBJECT TO THIS MOTION
THE BILL IS NOT YET IN PRINT WE
JUST BEEN HANDED THE AMENDMENTS
THERE'S NO DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE
SENATOR RIGHT.
THERE I HAVE A PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY.
IN YOUR PARLIAMENTARY KOREA'S
[inaudible]
YES.
ARE THE FINAL MMS FOR AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR AND PRINT
[inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
THAT.
THE DRESS IS NOT RECEIVED ANY
AMENDMENTS OF ON A. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR AT THIS POINT.
IF THE BILL IS NOT YET BEEN
AMENDED WILLIE AMENDED VERSION
OF THE BILL USE HE AMENDMENT
VERSION FROM WEDNESDAY NIGHT AT
SIX FORTY EIGHT PM.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT
CENTER.
THEN I THINK IT ON THE RECORD --
WE OBJECT TO THE MOTION BECAUSE
THE BILL IS NOT IN PRINT.
CIRCULAR CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
BY.
NO BRADFORD.
I CARRY AT ALL [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DALLY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ.
BY GROWTH HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TADO.
I JACKSON.
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
BY COUNTY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
NO.
ICE TWENTY TWO KNOWS.
EIGHT JOINT ROLLED TWENTY SIXTY
TWO A HAS BEEN WIFE.
WE'RE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
WITH SO -- TITLE. FOR TITLE I
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI TWENTY ONE KNOWS THREE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMOVING BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE
SIXTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE MR GLORIA FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
DUST WILL NOTE
.
IF THERE'S NO FURTHER BUSINESS
UP.
WHERE VISIBLE CONCEPTUALLY LAST
WEEK?
TO I KNOW LOS LITTLE WEIGHT.
SIR WELCOME FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THANK YOU MSTER PRESIDENT UNDER
A MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
PULL FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY SIX AB FIVE NINETY SIX
BY MR GRAYSON OP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THANK YOU THE DOES WILL NOTE.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
INTERACTION SUGGESTS IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
ALL OF THE IN HERE TODAY TO HELP
US GET SOME MORE COMPLETED.
BEFORE WE CLOSE I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ARE REPUBLICAN
LEADER OF COURSE IS NOT HERE
THIS MORNING SHE IS IN HER
COMMUNITY -- BECAUSE OF THE
EARTHQUAKE THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY AND I DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH HER EARLIER --
WE WANT TO SEND OUR THOUGHTS TO
HER IN HER COMMUNITY OF RICH
CHRIST.
HI SHE WANTED TO EXPRESS THE
GREAT APPRECIATION SHE HAS FOR
THE VERY QUICK RESPONSE OF YES
AND THE GOVERNOR'S -- QUICK
REACTION OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH
HER AS WE ADJOURNED FOR THE
WEEKEND I HOPE EVERYONE HAD A
WONDERFUL FOURTH OF JULY
CELEBRATION WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WE EXTEND OUR
THOUGHTS TO HER AND HER
COMMUNITIES.
AND LOOK FORWARD -- WE WILL
RECONVENE ON MONDAY JULY EIGHTH
AT TWO PM THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
INTO A GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED.
WE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT
TWO PM WE STAND IN RECESS